dos veces intentaron cazar por la fuerza
a Teresa uriana dos veces se escapó de
su ranchería tenía sólo 11 años pata en
[Música]
mayo el matrimonio infantil forzoso
dentro del pueblo wayú sigue siendo una
tradición en algunas familias para la
supervivientes las secuelas perduran en
el tiempo
[Música]
pese al silenciamiento y la
justificación de salvaguardar los usos y
costumbres nuevas generaciones de
mujeres wayú se resisten a esta
ancestralidad patriarcal después de mi
mamá ya entendemos Cuál es la
el vivir de uno pues no no ser violado
pero ya somos libres de violación
yo me he enamorado felizmente de mi
esposo sin perder su identidad a pesar
de las amenazas dentro y fuera de su
comunidad Jazmín Romero y piéyú
activista y feminista indígena wayú hace
su lucha desde el movimiento feminista
de mujeres y niñas con énfasis en las
áreas más remotas y aisladas de la
guajira también asesora a los familiares
de las víctimas de feminicidio como al
profesor Manuel eyeyú padre de janey
Elena violada y asesinada en 2021 está
en manos de la justicia ordinaria y que
queremos una respuesta que la
exigibilidad tanto de parte de nosotros
que somos activistas y de parte de
ustedes como acompañamos el proceso a
las víctimas Es que es que actúen ya de
una vez y no dilaten más los casos de
feminicidio es que hay en las
comunidades indígenas su hija tenía 17
años
como en otros casos de feminicidio en la
región el asesino sigue libre y nosotros
pues prácticamente no contamos el
respaldo de la justicia ni del estado en
esa parte
abanderando el feminismo indígena cada
vez son más las mujeres alzan la voz
desde dentro contra las opresiones y
violencia sexuales en sus comunidades